le moskva navire amiral de la flotte
russe dans la mer noire est désormais
sous l'eau mais comment ce croiseur
lance-missiles l'un des symboles de la
puissance de moscou at il pu couler à
cause d'un accident dû aux intempéries
selon le kremlin lors du remorquage du
croiseur moskva jusqu'au port de
destination le navire a perdu sa
stabilité des dommages à la coque sont
apparues à cause d'un incendie suite à
la détonation de munitions dans des
conditions de mer agitée le navire a
coulé mais kiev s'adjuge la
responsabilité de sa destruction qui
selon elle est le résultat de son tir de
missile le président ukrainien volodimir
hélène ce qui n'a pas manqué l'occasion
de le rappeler
l'international vient soutenir les
ukrainiens qui ont démontré que lenari
russes ne peuvent que couler adnot
washington et l'occident ont jusqu'à
présent refusé de commenter la nature de
l'incident ce naufrage constitue l'un
des plus gros revers pour moscou depuis
le début de la guerre et une perte
militaire très important le moskva
principalement chargé de la défense
aérienne en mer noire est le plus gros
navire russe à subir des dégâts de la
part d'un ennemi depuis 1941 c'est le
deuxième navire russe à être détruits
dans le conflit en cours après lorsque
touché dans le port de berlioz qu'en
mars dernier le moskva était en service
actif depuis 1986 ils devaient être
démantelées dans cinq ans seulement